en este vídeo vamos a aprender a
convertir números mixtos abstracciones
impropias y viceversa convertir de
fracciones impropias a números mixtos
entonces empecemos con lo básico que es
un número mixto
seguro ya has visto uno por ejemplo dos
enteros un medio
esto es un número mixto es una
composición de un número entero y una
parte fraccional por eso se llama así
número mixto y que es una fracción
impropia fracción
impropia
pues una fracción impropia es una
fracción cuyo numerador es más grande
que el denominador por ejemplo
sobre 5
23 quintos esto es una fracción impropia
porque el numerador el número de arriba
es más grande que el denominador el
número de abajo y resulta que se puede
pasar de una forma a la otra es decir se
puede pasar del número mixto a fracción
impropia y de fracción impropia al
número mixto vamos a empezar con
aprender a convertir del número mixto a
fracción impropia primero te voy a
enseñar la forma sistemática de hacerlo
y después ojalá te pueda dar un poco de
intuición de por qué este método
funciona veamos tomemos el número mixto
dos enteros un medio
entonces
en el numerador ir a 2
por 2
+ 1
más
y el denominador se queda igual que es 2
y ahora hagamos esta operación dos por
dos es cuatro más 15
5 medios es la fracción impropia que es
equivalente al número mixto dos enteros
un medio hagamos otro ejemplo tomemos
cuatro enteros dos tercios
y hacemos exactamente lo mismo que
hicimos arriba entonces en el numerador
va 3
por 4
+ 2
+ 2 y el denominador se queda igual que
es 3
y esto a que es igual hagamos esta
operación 3 por 4 es 12 2 14
catorce tercios es la fracción impropia
que es equivalente a cuatro enteros
dos tercios hagamos uno más me estoy
divirtiendo muchísimo
tomemos
seis enteros 17 18 años
y ahora si me puse una difícil
hagámosla entonces el denominador que
damos que se queda igual
y el numerador queda
por 6
más
17 y bueno 18 por 6 es igual a 108
nos queda 17 entre 18 y 108 17
es lo mismo que 125
125 18 años y listo ya convertimos este
número mixto
a esta fracción impropia ahora en este
punto vamos a dar un poco de intuición
es decir porque efectivamente este
método funciona
veamos tomemos este nuevo número mixto
dos enteros un cuarto y para que todos
sea más divertido vamos a ponerlos en
términos de pastel
qué rico entonces esto nos está diciendo
que tenemos dos pasteles
más un cuarto de pastel
que sería algo así dos pasteles y un
cuarto de pastel y entonces nos
preguntamos cuántos cuartos tengo en
total si este pastel lo divido en cuatro
partes
y este otro pastel también lo divide en
cuatro partes entonces nos queda 1 2 3 4
5 6
789 tenemos nueve pedazos de cuarto de
pastel y si nos vamos a la forma
sistemática que estábamos haciendo en la
parte izquierda que nos quedaba hacíamos
4 x 2
+ 1
entre 4
y cuatro por dos más uno
es 9
nueve cuartos que es exactamente la
misma cuenta que tenemos aquí ahora
vamos a aprender a pasar de una fracción
impropia a un número mixto
y para eso voy a tener que borrar lo que
hemos hecho para tener espacio entonces
tomemos una fracción impropia digamos
quintos y esto lo que nos está diciendo
es que tenemos 23 sobre 5 entonces
podemos hacer la división 23
entre 5
cuántas veces cabe el 5 en 23 5 por 4 es
20 y sobran 3 entonces esta fracción se
puede escribir como las veces que cabe 5
en 23 que es 4 y el residuo que es 3
quintos
es decir 23 quintos es equivalente al
número mixto cuatro enteros tres quintos
hagamos otro ejemplo
por ejemplo tomemos 17
octavos entonces tenemos que
preguntarnos cuántas veces cabe 8 en 17
y para ello dividimos 17 entre 8 8 por 2
es 16 y sobra 1 entonces 17 octavos es
equivalente a
dos enteros
porque el 8 cabe dos veces en 17 y hay
que poner el residuo qué es
octavo entonces diecisiete octavos es
equivalente a dos enteros un octavo
ahora vamos a darnos un poco de
intuición porque este método funciona
porque hasta ahora todo lo hemos hecho
de manera muy sistemática y para hacerlo
vamos a ponerlo en terminología de
pasteles qué rico probemos con la
fracción cinco medios cinco medios lo
que me está diciendo es que tengo cinco
mitades de pastel entonces tenemos
con la mitad
otra mitad
tres mitades
cuatro mitades y cinco mitades 1 2 3
55 mitades de pastel y vamos a contar
cuántos pasteles enteros tengo tengo 1
y 2
entonces tengo dos pasteles enteros y me
sobra uno
mitad de pastel ahora fíjate que si lo
hacemos de la forma sistemática es decir
como lo estábamos haciendo en la parte
izquierda esto que sería igual primero
tendríamos que hacer la división
5 entre 2 el 2 cabe dos veces en 5 2 por
2 4 y sobra uno entonces esta fracción
la puedo escribir como
los enteros
1 que es el residuo
me dio dos enteros un medio que es lo
que habíamos obtenido al hacerlo de los
pasteles y bueno pues espero que esto te
haya dado una muy buena intuición de lo
que está sucediendo cuando pasamos de
números mixtos a fracciones impropias y
viceversa y ahora si ya te puedes
divertir haciendo ejercicios